wait Cretu is here already
yes let's get pumped by pulling an 80s
classic out from the honest trailer
vault now that Star Wars is done for
good Roger Moore has walked away from
the Bond franchise and Superman 3 proved
were pretty tired of comic book movies
at least we still have rocky seriously
where could they possibly go from Rocky
3 make their kids fight each other
that'll be dumb rocky 4 you've seen
rocky punch Apollo Creed you've seen him
punch mr. t now get ready for rocky
Balboa's biggest challenge yet
punching communism in the face when a
Russian murders his worst enemy slash
best friend he'll seek revenge in a
showdown so epic it requires a training
montage
another training montage
and the third bonus montage of rocky
thinking about his past
training montages
man it's like a dream inside of a dream
is there a word for that now but it'll
take more than fancy editing to be Ivan
Drago a Soviet punching machine who's
bewildered by our strange American ways
like showgirls and electricity he's a
boxer of very few words only 46 in the
whole movie to be exact he does and
somehow this undefeated gold medalist
has taken our heroes by surprise forcing
rocky to fly all the way to Russia in
order to lift things run in the snow and
chop down trees sure he could have done
all that in Lake Tahoe
but yeah suck it you dirty commie trees
think you've seen everything the rocky
franchise has to offer you pow cuz
Paulie is still getting bullied Adrian
is still telling her bucks her husband
not to box and rocky is still bravely
soaking up punches with his face but
thrill as the old formula gets a shot of
new Reich with some updated geopolitics
against a futuristic talking robot
please make a wish you know it's
actually kind of sweet that stone put a
robot designed to help autistic kids in
the movie but also it's kind of weird
that he makes probably have sex with it
so if you're ready to see the Soviet
Union crumble one punch at a time but
you can't wait long enough to watch too
low help our brave Mujahideen friends do
it in the upcoming Rambo movie red rocky
remind the world that nobody messes with
the United States and gets away with it
especially not Russia
this guy's teeth out hell yeah man can
you imagine a future of Russia is still
the bad guy in Hollywood is still making
Rocky movies what am I saying
Willie the sci-fi to that Austrian dude
I'll be back
starry rant about bamboo From Russia
With Love robbed the robot definitely
ain't gonna be no rematch even redder
Sonia gene Shalit rocky eyes so wait if
rocky paulien adrian are all in russia
who's watching the kids excel see you're
with great power comes great
responsibility
farewell true believers the greatest
superpower is log you know i guess one
person can make a difference
nuff said